[Music]
in the spectacular setting of Windsor
Castle it was a unique event even for
Britain's longest-reigning monarch
[Music]
a small military parade to mark the
Queen's official birthday after trooping
the colour had to be cancelled because
of coronavirus only the second time it's
been called off in her 68 year reign the
Welsh Guards who were currently on guard
at Windsor Castle and a band of the
household division were doing the
honours but with new at ceremonial
drills reflecting these times of social
distancing during this pandemic of K vyd
they developed a way to make sure each
of the troops marching we're exactly 2.2
meters separate from one another and
they ensured that all the traditional
elements were still there the Queen was
saluted that guards were on parade and
Windsor looked fantastic this was the
first ceremonial event since the
pandemic started and the Queen was
keeping a close eye on every move with
fewer soldiers and more space there was
no room for any mistakes
Lieutenant Colonel Guy stone told me
that alongside their training the
household division have also been part
of a covert support force people join
the regiment's of the household division
very conscious of the dual role that we
have so whether that's on operations in
Afghanistan or Iraq or other places that
we've been over the over the past few
decades or having the huge privilege of
being personal bodyguards to the
sovereign but also in the last few weeks
they have been through what we have
called Operation Reese crypt delivering
support against this Koated crisis with
nothing to see outside of the castle the
usual royal watchers had stayed away but
not everyone was doing their bid for
social distancing the palace obviously
can't stop people gathering on a
beautiful summer's day but they have
done everything they possibly can to try
and keep the event low-key and stop
crowds from gathering in Windsor the
royal family are very aware at the
moment that everything they do is
potentially setting an example to the
rest of the country
[Music]
after taking the second salute the Queen
made her way inside properly to talk it
all over with Prince Phillip another new
experience to share even at the age of
94 Rhiannon Mills Sky News at Windsor
Castle